hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
simplicity that defies complexity the
maxima platform for
ultra high content imaging i am jennifer
woods of labrutz and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by miltonie
biotech
to learn more visit miltonibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
scientist miltoni biotech and dr marcus
hobbish global product manager at
miltonii biotech
dr king cabrala and dr habit you may now
begin your presentation
hello my name is ali kim kabala
my team at miltoni biotech has been
responsible for technology development
of the maxima imaging platform it
therefore gives me a special pleasure
today to introduce to you the product of
our
efforts over the past few years to
develop a fully automated platform for
serial immunofluorescence
in today's webinar marcus and i will
introduce you to the maxima
as well as to the process called mix
that is implemented on the platform to
generate serial stainings of a single
biological sample
in this webinar we will focus in
particular on explaining the underlying
technology and components that make this
high content staining possible
let's first consider the traditional
well-established methods for staining
biological samples
some of which have been around now for
over 100 years
these are still the mainstay of research
publications and clinically relevant
diagnostic approaches
the benefits of these established
methods is that they are well
characterized both their positive
aspects as well as their downsides
the equipment is also readily available
for most labs
the main drawback of these approaches
however is their limitation to at most a
few key markers for spatial analysis
which is insufficient to understand
complex biological systems
with the novel technology employed by
the maxima imaging platform these
limitations are resolved
but the maxima one can stain and analyze
over 100 markers on a single sample
this thereby permits fine-tuned
phenotyping of the spatial organization
of complex biological systems
such as the tumor micro environment this
high content approach
can help drive forward cancer and
immunotherapy research
shown in this image is the color-coded
merger of eight important
marker images from a 150 marker run
segmentation of the individual cells
allows a flow type analysis of
individual cell intensities but this
time with over 150
marker intensities we can perform either
manual gating or blind fully automated
clustering
of over all 150 markers to identify
important subpopulations or novel
cell types present in the sample
in this particular case the clustering
results match our prior knowledge of
which markers should stain which types
of cells
very well
as we have shown in prior webinars this
is not of merely theoretical
relevance we've previously shown that
ultra high content imaging with a maxima
can be used to reveal and characterize
tertiary lymphoid structures and other
aspects of the tumor microenvironment in
cell populations and different samples
of ovarian carcinoma
we've also presented the many different
analysis strategies possible when you
apply 150 plus markers to lung
adenocarcinoma
and lung squamous cell carcinoma samples
these analysis approaches are available
with our user-friendly qi tissue image
analysis software that marcus will
present at the end
we have also recently published a
holistic screening based approach
using the maxima to identify new targets
in pancreatic adenocarcinoma that can be
used for carcinocar t
immunotherapy more information regarding
these topics can be found on our website
for conventional immunofluorescent
staining of a biological sample
the number of markers is limited by the
number of overlapping dies that can be
applied at the same time to the sample
this imposes a hard limit to the number
of possible simultaneous markers
but what if we could reuse the same dyes
in the cyclic fashion
this is what we achieve with maxima
imaging cyclic
staining or mix technology
it's important to note the maxima
imaging platform goes hand in hand with
our mix technology
our platform has been designed to
optimally carry out this
mixed process on a biological sample
consisting of a staining step an imaging
step
and an erasure step that then allows for
the next staining
in contrast to other approaches to high
content staining based on complicated or
costly reagents that may also require
sophisticated
proprietary equipment mix is based on
the simple and trusted method
of traditional immunofluorescence and
can be carried out on our now
commercially available
maximum with this process of mix
being possible to continue essentially
seemingly indefinitely
as long as you have antibodies our
current record is over 400 markers on
the same sample
in this webinar we want to give you
insight into the four main pillars of
the maxima imaging platform
it's an entire platform all under one
roof
with full compatibility and a congruent
workflow
let's first focus on the technology
underlying the maxima instrument
itself the maxima
is a seamless and fully automated fusion
of a pipetting robot
a precision stage and a microscope
while a microfluidic approach could have
also been considered for the maxilla
the application of in development of
microfluidic handling
to samples mounted within novel flow
chambers is not easy
there are a lot of technical hurdles
that must be overcome and the
development time would have
taken much longer we therefore focused
on a macrofluidic handling approach
that we also recognized allows us to
easily process standard
biological samples in an open well type
plate format the needle technology
employed by the maxima is directly
inherited from our decades-long
development of flow cytometers
for both the maxima and flow cytometry
the precise pipetting of buffer as well
as the avoidance of carry over from one
pipetting step to the next
or from one well to the next well is
paramount
fortunately these problems were solved
already years ago at milton e for
flow devices the principal solution
these problems is based on an efficient
walk-in washing
mechanism for the needle that washes it
both internally and externally between
each step it was therefore easy for us
to adapt this in-house technology to the
maxima
macrofluidic handling in essence allows
us to apply our cyclic staining process
to the conventional open well plates and
chambers that are in daily use by the
research community
as a user you will be able to use
standard sample preparation of tissue
slices or adherence cells
in standard disposable
plates and then plug and play the
instrument takes care of the rest
for the automated microscope we have
focused on hitting a sweet spot
balancing resolution and magnification
to ensure sufficient resolution
to visualize in segment cells while at
the same time ensuring a low enough
magnification
to efficiently scan large samples the
maxima comes with
multiple air objectives one 2x objective
as well as two 20x objectives matched to
the one millimeter thick
standard objective glass or 170 micron
thick standard
thick coverslip glass the maximum
resolution is set by the high end
objectives
and the observation wavelength and
ranges down to roughly 400 nanometers
we have four principal channels
available one for dappy to take images
of the nucleus
from cycle to cycle so we can easily
register the images from each cycle to
each other
plus three separate channels for
staining in each mixed cycle
in this slide i would like to present
some novel results that we are preparing
for submission
that are based on a comparison between
the maxima
and a flow cytometer the max quant
so what we see here are cells that are
stained for cd3
with a label probe we have spiked in
for the different label pro percentages
shown here
different amounts different percentages
of an unlabeled version
of the antibody this allows us to scan
the entire dynamic range of detection
and especially in this regime where it's
difficult
it seems difficult to distinguish the
positive and negative populations
one can make a a direct comparison of
flow
on these blood cells these label blood
cells with the maxima
flow is shown the flow cytometry results
are shown in orange
and show that in d here that the
positive and negative populations are
starting to be hard to
distinguish you can see the positive
fraction here as only a shoulder
at roughly 100 proteins per cell but the
maxima has a much
narrower negative population to begin
with
it has a broad positive population which
is mostly due to biological
heterogeneity
underlying in the cells if we continue
to go down to even lower concentrations
of label probe lower
percentages of label probe all the way
down to roughly
10 labeled proteins per cell we can
still detect that as a
as a shoulder a distinguishable shoulder
with a maxima
showing that with the maxima we are able
to achieve a factor of 10 higher
sensitivity than with a flow cytometer
in the next section i would like to
discuss some of the disposables that we
offer for use
with our system
as i've emphasized above we strive to
make our system as compatible as
possible with standard sample mounting
for microscopy
with this in mind we've developed three
lines of disposable slides for mounting
your samples
the maxwell imaging frames with either
one two or four wells
are compatible with standard microscope
slides for use with thin
tissue sections our maxwell 24 plates
allow for culturing of adherence cells
and come with a 170 micron thick
coverslip glass
bottom and our upcoming disposables for
suspension cells come in plate or slide
format
and consist of millions of imprinted
micro cavities that allow
trapping of individual cells for ultra
high content analysis
of suspension cells like blood samples
will now turn the presentation over to
marcus who will describe the other two
pillars of the maxima imaging platform
thank you very much ali and welcome to
all webinar attendees from my side
my name is marcus harvey and i'm global
product manager
for imaging reagents at miltoni biotech
and it's my pleasure to introduce to you
today our maxima imaging platform
and after ali focused on the
instrument and the sample carriers i
would now
continue on giving you some insight
into the antibodies that can be used for
the mix technology and
how antibodies by milton biotech
specially support the mixed technology
so ali explained to you the basic
principle of the mixed technology
which is built on a cyclic
immunofluorescence
staining method i would like to open the
quad
the chapter on antibodies with the basic
question which
antibodies are actually compatible with
mix
and antibodies compatible for mix are
fluorochrome conjugated primary
antibodies
this means that we use here a direct
immunofluorescence
staining approach where the primary
antibodies are directly conjugated
with fluorochromes this is in contrast
to an indirect immunofluorescence
approach
where fluorochrome conjugated secondary
antibodies are used
to detect non-labeled primary antibodies
so these primary antibodies they further
need to be conjugated to
erasable fluorochromes this is important
because the mix technology is as i said
cyclic immunofluorescence method
and it is important that after each
cycle
the fluorescent signal is erased
to allow staining and imaging in the
next cycle
which eurasia methods and what
erasable fluorochromes actually means i
will explain
in a couple of slides from here
and third these antibodies need to be
compatible with
fixed samples so the mix technology
is optimized for analyzing fixed samples
so either tissue sections
or cells which is then referred to as
immunohistochemistry p for paraffin
embedded tissues
or f for frozen tissues or
immunocytochemistry
icc respectively
to break down this question which
antibodies are compatible with mix
the simple answer is on one hand mix
validated antibodies by miltoni biotech
so we provide a
pre-validated portfolio of antibodies
that we internally already tested and
that are compatible
and ready for use inside a mixed
experiment
but also what is important to state here
is that the maxima imaging platform
is not a closed system but an open
system
meaning that you can use any other
antibody conjugate
that meets the requirements as listed
here
so if you have a fluorochrome conjugated
primary antibody
that is used in your lab for example
already
you can test it for the mixed technology
and
if compatible you can use it in the
ultra high
content imaging analyses
so in the next slides i would like to
focus on the mix validated antibodies by
miltoni biotech
and their features they bring along
the first aspect of course the most
important one i mentioned already that
these antibodies are validated
specifically for the mixed technology
and are validated in-house for
compatibility
another important thing an aspect when
looking now at a technology that allows
analysis
of over 100 markers on one single sample
is that you have access
to an extensive catalog of antibodies
and up to now the mix validated antibody
portfolio by militantly biotech
contains antibodies to detect more than
500 antigens
of human or mouse samples
that are brought together by over 800
antibody clones
and since we conjugate them to different
fluorochromes to allow multiplexing
within
each cycle of the experiment we're
looking at
a total catalog of over 2000 antibody
conjugates
that are readily available for building
your own panel and designing your mix
experiment
so let's have a closer look at the
testing procedure
for mix validated antibodies
in our routine tests reference samples
with known marker expression
meaning positive control tissues are
used for
sample preparation that includes
fixation
and slicing of the tissue
routinely we test our antibodies
with three different fixation methods
the first one is
on formalin fixed paraffin embedded
tissues
abbreviated as ffpe
and associated to this fixation method
are often antigen retrieval protocols
and for this we use one specific
protocol that is based on heat induced
epitope retrieval at a ph of 9
meaning that all our ffpe validated
antibodies
have been validated using this epitope
retrieval protocol
further fixation methods for cryo
sections
but also fixed cells include using four
percent
paraform aldehyde or pfa
but also acetone fixation
so after sample preparation these
sections are then
immunostained in a characteristically
short immune stating step of 10 minutes
the stain image is acquired and
the signal is erased
and finally both images
stain image and the erase image are
analyzed
in regards to antibody specificity
signal intensity we do determine a
recommended dilution
and also the signal erasure
after explaining the catalog size and
the validation
procedure i would like to explain to you
that the mix antibody portfolio consists
of
recombinantly engineered antibodies
and we have different groups of
recombinantly engineered antibodies
that perfectly supports the mixed
technology
and the different eurasia mechanisms
that are used
let's have a closer look at the
different types of recombinantly
engineered
antibodies tailored for mix on one hand
antibodies of the rear affinity class
consist of full length antibodies that
are conjugated
to fluorochromes on the other hand we
have a technology
that can be grouped as releasable
antibodies
and they consist of rare diles
antibody complexes or rear lease
antibody complexes
that are based on the same technology
and allow
in the mixed cycle the specific release
of fluorochromes
and they consist of recombinantly
engineered antibody binding fragments
that are conjugated via a linker to
fluorochromes and
the benefits of recombinantly
engineering these antibodies
i would like to explain to you here
which is
on one hand that of course you can by
engineering the dna and the amino acid
sequence
of the epitope binding regions you can
influence
the binding characteristics of the
antibodies
and can increase the specificity for
these antibodies which we did
selected for the highest specificity
binders another thing that is possible
is to mutate the full-length antibodies
here for example
in this fc region which is part of the
constant chain of
immunoglobulins that normally cause
background signal from binding to fc
gamma receptor
molecules that are expressed on immune
cells
in the sample being analyzed and
these three affinity antibodies they
contain mutations
in this area that prevent the
generation of this background signal
and also in our releasable antibody
technology
we engineered them in a way that no fc
region is expressed at all thereby again
eliminating any background signal
that would derive from fc gamma receptor
binding
and one very important point is that
because of recombinant manufacturing
what you would result in is a very high
lot to lot consistency
meaning that every lot is the same and
performs consistently
consistently which is crucial for the
reproducibility
of high content experiments
i mentioned that these recombinantly
engineered antibodies
are perfectly designed for the mixed
technology
and support the eurasia mechanisms
that are used and of those there are two
different
ones on one hand we are able to erase
the fluorescence signal
via a process referred to as
photobleaching
and second we have process that is
referred to as
fluorochrome release
what this means i would like to give you
a detailed explanation in the next slide
let's focus first on photobleaching of
fluorochromes
here full-length antibodies are
conjugated
to photosensitive fluorochromes
and these fluorochromes here listed
fit c p e and apc they are well known in
the field of flow cytometry
but less common in imaging
however the great benefits that they
provide are
very bright signals but still
susceptibility to photobleaching
and this is employed here in the mix
technology as follows
i would like to explain to you this
based on here a mouse lymph node
as fixed using acetone you can see here
the adapti staining showing the nuclei
and here in this image this is the
section stained with a cd4
fit c conjugate in the schematic
representation you can see here the
entire
sample is stained with the antibody
but only the region of interest here is
imaged
in the next step the region of interest
is illuminated with light and thereby
the signal of the fluorochromes
is erased by photobleaching
and this leads to a very efficient
signal erasure
that is shown here so both
images do show the same contrast
adjustments and you can appreciate the
efficiency
of the signal erasure here which is a
prerequisite
for the cyclic immunostaining because
what you can do now
is to stain the same sample again with
another
conjugate of the same fluorochrome in
this example cd45r
fit c has been used and this process can
continue over and over you can do
photo bleach again and continue with the
next cycles
so let's have a look at the second
eurasia mechanism
which is called controlled fluorochrome
release
and this is used using two novel
technologies of antibodies
rheodylies antibodies but also realise
antibodies
are functional for that and in this
example i would like to show you here
this human pancreas
section that has been pfa fixed here
again is the
darpy signal and on the right hand side
you see the same section that has been
stained with
cytokeratin pe conjugate
here below you see the schematic
representation
once again and this erasure mechanism
is based on the incubation which with
the substance
that causes the dissociation of the
antibody complexes
and thereby triggers the release of
fluorochromes from the sample
which can then be washed away
accordingly resulting in a very
efficient
signal erasure again here
you see same contrast adjustments so you
can appreciate
the efficiency of the signal eraser
which can then in turn serve to a
restaining using the
same fluorochromes which has been
performed here in this example
using a cytokeratin 19 pe conjugate
which again can be erased and
continued with the next cycles
so for ease of explanation i showed you
before
the examples for single channel
staining and erasure but of course
what is done is to multiplex within each
cycle
so here you see a human tonsil section
that has been stained with three
different
antibody conjugates in this example cd28
apc cd19 fitzy and cd4
pe was used on the same sample
here you can appreciate the three color
image
and then again after incubation
with this reagent the dissociation
of antibody complexes is triggered
leading then to a fluorochrome release
from the sample and a
efficient signal erasure from the sample
and with this all three channels are now
available again for
restaining this has been done here using
cd11c
apc cd45ra fitzy
and cd3 pe and you can appreciate here
the different staining pattern so with
continuing this you accumulate
this high content data as we showed you
earlier
the benefit here from this antibody
technology is that you're able to
erase the signal from the entire sample
at once
photobleaching is limited to a certain
area of illumination
while here this signal erasure method
allows now
in one incubation step to erase the
signal of the entire sample at once
one side note i would like to make here
when explaining the signal erasure
mechanisms is
that you don't have to decide for one
erasure mechanism per experiment but
only per cycle meaning that
in one experiment you can combine both
eurasia mechanisms as wished
and with this i would like to mention
the fourth aspect
of the mix validated antibodies is that
they come
in optimized formats
for this we offer three different
formats
on one hand these antibodies are
available as
dissolved antibodies in form of vials
and they are ready to use for pipetting
a reagent plate that would be the input
for the experiment and this allows very
flexible
panel design and preparation of the
experiment but to make it even easier
what we developed are ready to use dried
antibody panel plates they are referred
to as
heya screen they come in different
flavors
so on one hand we offer predefined
panels
and those are 96 well panel plates
that contain the dried antibody reagents
and offer highly standardized and
error-free analysis
because what you would do is just to
enter the sealed plate
into the maxima instrument and
start the experiment and the
reconstitution
and pipetting is all done inside the
instrument
in a fully automated fashion
in this predefined panels also of course
the antibody panel
is already pre-configured by miltani
meaning that you don't have to actively
invest in panel design
however what is of course also wished
for is
customizable panels where users can then
based on their very specific needs and
applications
combine a antibody panel
and with this antibody format
customizable panels
users are able to order their
customized panel as these ready-to-use
reagent plates
thereby having very standardized and
error-free
customized panels ready for analysis
so after explaining to you in details on
the antibodies
i would like to continue to the last
component of the maxima imaging platform
which is the image analysis software
so this image analysis software is
called qi
tissue and has been specifically
developed
for the maxima imaging platform
and is able in very different so fast
sophisticated manners to analyze
the ultra high content imaging data
that has been acquired in mixed
experiments
so among many other functionalities that
qr tissue brings along i would like to
briefly mention four different
functionalities that we will have a
closer look at
now just listed they are browsing
through
the markers you're able to segment your
cells
to further gate and sub-gate to identify
cellular populations
but also to display your high content
data
in a clustering method and also in
disney plot representation as an example
so let's have a closer look how this
looks if you upload
your data into qa tissue so what you're
able to see here
on the left side are the different
marker images
that have been acquired they are
displayed according to
the colors indicated here which is
freely
customizable and you can toggle on and
can toggle off
the individual marker pictures that you
would like to be displayed
in combination
the next example is segmentation and
this is a crucial step at the beginning
of analysis of cell-based
expression profiles and what it means
actually
is to define this the nuclei and the
cellular boundaries
of each cell and thereby
allowing to analyze
the expression level of all the
different markers you have detected
for each cell individually
with a maxima imaging platform you can
use a multitude of different
segmentation markers
on one hand in a manual fashion but also
in automated manners
here the third point i want to make is
gating and sub gating
which is a interactive functionality
here in qa tissue
you see here on the left side the tissue
that has been acquired and on the right
hand side
you see a scatter plot as you would know
it from flow cytometry
and here each dot in the scatter plot
is referring to one cell in your tissue
sample and the interactivity here
allows drawing gates on the sample
itself or in the scatter plot
with displaying in the other
representation respectively
and this means you can draw your gates
and analyze sub-populations of cells
subsequently
furthermore we offer in qi tissue
clustering methods for example here
and you could see in a heat map
representation
cells that have been clustered according
to their similarity in market expression
but also the reduction of dimensionality
is possible using so-called tis knee
plots
that allow here to display each cell as
a single dot
and display also the similarities
in between the different cells to make
it easier
to grasp the high content data that has
been acquired
important to mention is also that you
can
export all the different analyses that
you made
as values in csv or scs formats
which allows you to extract the numeric
values for further
downstream analyses in your individual
pipelines
this brings me to the end of today's
webinar which i would like to conclude
with the following take-home messages
first ali showed you that the maxima
imaging platform
allows true cellular phenotyping of
complex systems
such as the tumor microenvironment and
he gave different examples of studies
that we
showed so far already where you can get
an insight
how the maxima imaging platform can
serve
for this application
second we alluded to the fact that the
mixed technology
is now breaking the limits of spatial
multiplex analysis
by offering to analyze more than 100
markers on one
individual sample and thereby
revolutionizing
the multiplexing field allowing
really to identify all the cellular
populations
inside one complex sample
and finally we showed you that the
maxima imaging platform
consists of a full and integrated set of
instrument sample carriers validated
antibodies and
a powerful image analysis software
and with this i would like to thank you
very much for
attending today's webinar and for
joining
and ali and me are happy to take your
questions now in the approaching
q a session so please feel free to enter
your question
and looking forward to exchange with you
thank you
thank you dr king cabuella and dr
hobbish for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how difficult is it to operate the
instrument what is the level of
expertise needed thank you very much
jennifer
i think i can take this question so
basically it is very very simple to
operate
the maxima imaging system because
there are only uh very few steps that
you have to
initiate before starting an experiment
and basically
doing the experiments the instrument is
performing all steps in a fully
automated manner
this means that the antibodies are
resuspended are applied to the sample
images are being acquired signal is
being erased all in a fully automated
manner that is
supported by the liquid handling inside
the instrument
basically the only thing that
requires more preparation is before you
start an experiment with hundreds of
markers
you need to define your antibody panel
and
to collect the antibodies that you would
like to stain with
and also to assemble them in
cycles according to your panel of
interest
this requires some preparation um
that yeah i would say needs a well
thought
process but other than that starting the
system
operating it um is fairly easy
and can be started by any
would you say lab trained person
all right thank you so much our next
question is
how can you be sure that the
fluorochrome release doesn't
excuse me four cl fluorochrome release
treatment does not affect the sample or
epitopes
all right honey if it's okay i would
also take this question and maybe you
can add
um if there's anything so the
fluorochrome release
is based on the rhea dailies or realise
antibody complexes and when developing
these complexes we ensured that
the molecules that are used for
generating the scaffold are not present
on
any cells or tissues that you would
analyze
using the maxima and thereby
we are also sure that this does not
affect
any sample morphology or sample
integrity
this was very intensely tested
and over very long experiments also over
several hundreds of markers that are
applied with the fluorochrome release
technology
and you would not detect any
a deteriorating effect on the sample or
on detecting
the um the same antibodies after
sequential cycles so it was specifically
designed for
this technology and therefore in-house
we validated this extensively being sure
that this has no
effect
thank you dr hobbish i think we're
having a little trouble connecting
um ali so we'll i'll just keep asking
you some questions and then when he's
reconnected
he can feel free to answer or add to
anything
the next question
what material is given to remove or
erase the antibodies
yes so the exact identity of course
is confidential and owned by military
biotech but
in principle it's a chemical based
release mechanism where the antibody
complexes that i showed you that consist
of antibody fragments
a scaffold or also called linker
that is conjugated then to the
fluorochromes and
this chemical step is a
short incubation step with the chemical
that leads to the dissociation
of the scaffold or linker and
thereby causing the fluorochromes
to release it is not
based on on a reductive mechanism so
it's not
a harsh chemical treatment but it's a
very mild and gentle
treatment that can also be used to
incubate
life cells this is for example done with
our release technology
during after cell sorting so after the
release steps these cells can be used
for any other assays
and were proven to not
take any deleterious effect due to the
incubation
with this chemical and since we're using
um fixed samples inside the maximum and
not live cells i think we're pretty sure
that
there are no tremendous effects here and
um yeah that the process is not affected
in
any negative way thank you
thank you dr hobbish it looks like we
have uh dr king gabala back as well
so uh if you have anything to add to
that feel free
otherwise i'm going to ask the next next
question
okay our next question is is it possible
to erase
only one stain in a cycle in a
multi-staining process
now this is a question that you would
like to cover or should i answer
okay i'm not sure if ali is back or
still
connection there he is he he was muted
but now he's not do you hear us
ollie can you hear me
yes okay good it seems to have uh
yeah the wheel is spinning let's say um
but
it's good that you can hear me yes so it
is possible to
uh the question was to release or to
um to remove a single
uh stain from a multi uh stain sample
correct and um without perturbing the
others yes that is possible
with both mechanisms of erasure through
photobleaching or through
um the release process
fantastic do you have anything to add dr
habish
not from my side thank you okay moving
on the next question
[Music]
what kind of antibodies are basically
used for the staining process
basically the antibodies that you use in
the
maxima platform or the mixed technology
are
primary conjugated antibodies so
and this is what i mentioned during the
presentation it is based on direct
immunofluorescence
and for example in the case of
photobleaching
these antibodies those could be
monoclonal antibodies for example
they're then conjugated to
um erasable fluorochromes like fizzy p
and apc that are available
for photo bleaching by light
illumination and offer thereby
the the erasure of the fluorescent
signal
to allow them to initiate the next
staining cycle
and to use the same furochrome to stain
again
so this is intrinsic to this technology
that you use
primary conjugated antibodies
there is the possibility so a lot of
times the question comes up
as well can you use secondary antibodies
for signal amplification
and basically um these fulcrums that we
use they
provide a very good signal to background
ratio so
for the vast majority of markers it is
not necessary to
introduce a signal amplification step
in case it's a very sensitive marker
that you would like to analyze there is
however the possibility
to include a secondary antibody staining
step in the very first
mixed cycle the problem is that you
cannot do this in each cycle because
there is only a limited
number of host species that you could
use with the primary antibody and target
with the secondary antibody
and due to the cyclic nature of the
mixed technology you would
keep protecting the same antibodies
with one whole species of using this for
multiple cycles
and this is basically why you are
limited to primary conjugates but as
said
the possibility still exists to make use
of secondary
antibody staining in the very first
cycle
all right thank you dr hobbish we'll
move on to the next question
how long does a staining cycle of 50
markers take
for one sample
and don't forget to unmute if you would
like to answer
you want to go ahead ali yes sorry sorry
i think
had problems with the news um yeah so
for 50
stains if we can do them three at a time
as marcus has presented with three
different floor fours
the staining time is a few minutes the
erasure time is a few minutes
imaging is less than a minute on the
single sample
so you can do three markers in roughly
20 minutes
and therefore nine markers in an hour
and then
yeah therefore 50 markers then in
roughly five or six hours on a single
sample
depends a little bit on how many how
much imaging you would like to do how
many samples you would like to do
how many fields you would like to
acquire but roughly that is correct and
for a single
tissue sample
all right thank you ali our next
question
does photo bleaching damage the sample
i can also take that if you want uh
marcus um so that's something that that
we looked into extensively in
in my group and um
what the wavelengths that we are using
um
are red green and blue uh wavelengths
so uh the bleaching photobleaching is um
generated by high-powered
leds in those wavelengths and we've
purposefully avoided
therefore wavelengths
shorter wavelengths close to the uv that
would be more likely to induce
damage and um yes
so we have then tested hundreds of
cycles
and have shown no noticeable effect by
photobleaching
for a few minutes after each cycle with
these powerful leds
on the antigenicity of of the next uh
antibodies
[Music]
paintings
thank you dr king cable our next
question
how can you ensure that the signal from
one cycle is not detected in the
subsequent cycle
in case the signal isn't erased
yes i can probably take that that's uh
marcus as well
um one thing that that we do we
as marcus said we verify that the
release
mechanism um occurs with a certain
efficiency
but there can be a rest amount that is
very low in intensity
and was not even visible in the images
that
marcus showed but there can still be a
tiny amount
and because we have a cyclic imager and
we have the image
before the staining as well as the
stained image
unlike for conventional
immunofluorescence you only have the
stained image
we can actually subtract the pre-stain
image from the stain image
all of the images are registered with
each other so we can do this on a sub
the subpixel
accuracy is subtraction so any residual
fluorescence that may be from the prior
stainings all of the prior cumulative
stainings
is additionally removed through this
additional subtraction step
thank you dr king kobala next question
is it necessary to optimize the
condition of photo bleaching and
photochrome releasing
on the customer end i would assume right
um
no it's not necessary for the customer
to do any further optimization
beyond what what we have already done to
ensure that the
efficiency is very high for both and
that the
rest residual intensity is removed
through the subtraction
exactly maybe just to add on this so
basically all the conditions they are
pre-evaluated
by us so that you can just start the
experiment and you do not
need to further optimize any settings
the operating software will allow
however to adjust
certain parameters so in case you're not
happy with the default settings
there is the possibility also to change
exposure erasure times and so on
so this is possible
all right thank you both and we have an
um
time for just another question here how
does the technology cope with auto
autofluorescent tissues excuse me
autofluorescent tissues
yes so i can take that um so
very what's very nice about a setup as
well
um for conventional immunofluorescence
you would normally just stain your
tissue and and deal with the
consequences of highly autofluorescent
material
and try to try to sort out what is real
staining from
the autofluorescent background and in
those cases you also don't have
normally a priest a pre-stained image of
the autofluorescence of your sample
that you could easily subtract in our
case because we have a cyclic
instrument we can um
if we if we started with a highly
autofluorescent material
we would anyway have that pre-stained
image that we could subtract from the
next stain
but we go an additional step further
because we have leds
that we do use anyway to photobleach our
our antibody conjugates we can we use
those photo
bleaching leds to also bleach the
autofluorescence
and we can do this um to an efficiency
of over 90
for the typical types of samples
that marcus mentioned with the different
fixation methods typical
autofluorescence we can remove over 90
of that
with a 10 minute bleaching in a 3x3
millimeter spot
for each tissue before starting even the
cycles
that's staining
[Music]
great thank you so much uh anything to
add uh
dr hobbish i think he answered that one
pretty good thanks yes thank you
okay i will take one more audience
question before we move on uh
and then wrap up one more question what
if a student has
rgb color blankness is there a way he
she will be able to understand which
cell is which
basically this is no problem at all
because the qi tissue
software allows to false color
all the black and white images that you
would obtain
in any method that you want so and you
might have seen
in the screen grab that i showed earlier
that there is a
complete spectrum of colors you can
toggle on and toggle off
and this is very customizable so
depending on the needs
of students or operators this can be
adjusted accordingly
all right thank you for that dr hobash
well thank you both dr king kabala and
dr hobbish do you have any final
comments for the audience today
only just to thank you for attending the
webinar yes sorry marcus go ahead
no worries ali um exactly the same i
would like to say um thanks a lot for
joining today's webinar and
um it was a pleasure presenting this to
you and discussing with your
your questions and if there is any open
question please don't hesitate
to send it to labra roots or to miltoni
directly and we would like to cover this
subsequently thanks a lot thank you very
much
well thank you again to our speakers dr
ali king kabula and dr marcus hobbish
for your time today and for your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor miltoni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye